ich begrüße ganz herzlich eben münchen
die biologin ulrike protzer frau protz
frage auch an sie die zahl der
schwererkrankten deutschlandweit liegt
bei 300 die kliniken sind also bei
weitem nicht überfordert die totenzahlen
steigen auch nicht rasant kann es
deshalb nicht deshalb sondern kann es
dennoch in ihren augen zu einem kollaps
kommen also ich glaube im moment sind
wir zum glück in deutschland in einer
stabilen lage
weil wir vorhin gesagt haben die
pandemie haben wir die im griff der mir
natürlich nicht im griff die pandemie
wie der name schon sagt geht ja weltweit
vor sich und wir wissen viele viele
länder haben es überhaupt nicht im griff
selbst unsere europäischen nachbarn
haben deutlich mehr probleme als wir
aber wir in deutschland haben zum glück
sowohl die erste liste
infektionsgeschehen sie hat relativ gut
überstanden
können wir darüber diskutieren warum
warum das so ist
wir waren neun tage hinter italien und
haben zum glück diese neun tage genutzt
muss ich sagen aber auch im moment ich
bin immer ein gegner davon zu sagen wir
sind schon in der zweiten welle das sind
wir einfach nicht wir haben kein
exponentielles wachstum
wir haben in dem moment in dem wir einen
anstieg gesehen haben direkt wieder
reagiert die menschen haben mitgemacht
und zum glück sind wir ja selbst in
münchen heute wieder unter die 50
gefallen oder unter die kritische grenze
gefallen
insofern denke ich bisher haben wir
eigentlich in deutschland ziemlich
rational reagiert und wie ich finde auch
sehr gut reagieren alles dennoch einen
kollaps geben kann das noch kommen
ich bin auch kein wahrsager und kann
natürlich mich in die zukunft schauen
was es noch geben kann
ich denke wenn wir weiterhin die
menschen mitnehmen können und das ist
sicher extrem wichtig dass wir das
erklären können was wir machen dass wir
auch sagen okay liebe liebe mitbürger
wenn wir zu dem punkt kommen da müssen
wir die maßnahmen machen aber wenn wir
sehen die zahlen gehen wieder zurück
können wir das auch wieder lockern
ich glaube wenn wir so auf einer guten
ebene rational gesteuert arbeiten können
dann können wir so ein kollaps
verhindern haben wir mehr infizierte
frau weil wir mehr testen oder haben wir
mehr infizierte weil die sich wirklich
infiziert in deutschland und nicht
wer anderswo also beides wir haben mir
getestet dadurch detektieren wir
natürlich mehr
aber auch insgesamt die absolute zahl
der infizierten steigt unabhängig von
den tests unsere trefferquote ist höher
geworden aber wir haben definitiv mehr
das kam sicherlich durch die
urlaubsrückkehrer das kam auch dadurch
ja wir hatten nach den ganzen maßnahmen
im frühjahr natürlich auch im sommer so
eine gewisse entspannung uns verdient
und das war auch gut so dass wir die
genutzt haben dass das war die situation
die wir hatten nach den ferien macht das
ja gesehen in nordrhein-westfalen in
anderen bundesländern
wenn die ferienzeit wenn die rückreise
wieder weg war dann ging auch die zahlen
wieder runter und das ist zum glück das
was wir jetzt auch in bayern im moment
sehen bayern ging als letztes in die
ferien hat natürlich auch die
schlechteste ausgangslage weil in europa
um uns herum schon am meisten los war
aber auch hier gehen jetzt gerade im
moment zum glück die zahlen wieder
zurück ok bei uns ist sybille
katzenstein mit einer corona
schwerpunktpraxis vor katzenstein sitzen
sie in berlin neukölln
wie viele tests machen sie in der woche
wie viele sind positiv also in der
letzten woche waren 85 von montag bis
freitag positiv
das ist viel so viel hatte ich noch nie
200 bis 300 tester am tag
und wenn es darum geht ob wir immer mehr
regeln irgendwie etablieren müssen also
mein gefühl ist zumindest wenn ich meine
praxis als seismograph nehme dass die
bevölkerung eigentlich mitmachen möchte
wie möchten sich tasten lassen und die
schlange von meiner praxis ist 200 meter
lang und die leute drehen sich trotzdem
nicht um und gehen wieder nach hause das
würde ich wahrscheinlich machen wenn ich
so eine schlange sehen würde sondern sie
möchten sich testen lassen und was ich
eigentlich nicht verstehe ist warum es
den menschen irgendwie so schwer gemacht
wird ein test ran zu kommen also
normalerweise sollte man doch wenn man
krank wird möglichst schnell irgendwie
getestet werden damit das containment
überhaupt noch greifen kann und nicht in
online terminen zwei wochen kriegen
deswegen teste ich ohne termine also die
leute kommen einfach deswegen ist meine
quote wahrscheinlich auch so viel höher
also ich nicht er bei 8 prozent wie bei
und sie würden sich wünschen dass das
einfach schneller geht auch im sinne
ihrer patienten würden sie denn auch
sagen wir müssten jetzt mal wirklich ein
bisschen loki fahren und ein bisschen
entwarnung geben oder habe ich ganz jung
aber ist also ich würde erstmal sagen
die maßnahmen müssten noch ausgeschöpft
worden werden wo menschen eigentlich
sich an der pandemie bekämpfung
beteiligen wollen und das ist gar nicht
so einfach als patient also es dauert
nach wie vor eben einen test zu bekommen
wenn man das möglichst schnell haben
möchte und genau und es gebe auch viel
einfachere methoden weil in diesen
schlanken stellen sich ja auch kranke
menschen an die fieber haben
ich habe am anfang der pandemie den
selbst abstrich praktiziert als es noch
keinem ersten gab das wurde dann auch
toleriert aber in dem moment wo masken
auf dem markt werden ist mir das
untersagt wurden von der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung und ich
kann es nach wie vor nicht
nachvollziehen wenn ein mensch krank ist
soll er nicht mit der u-bahn zur praxis
fahren
er soll bis kreuz infektionen vermeiden
und es gibt ja die methode also es wird
auch in anderen ländern praktiziert test
muss zum patienten und nicht andersrum
fragen wir gleich noch mal auf frau
teichert haben sie befürchtungen dass
mit der steigenden zahl der infizierten
tatsächlich auch mehr menschen schwer
erkranken und schwerst erkrankten
ich glaube das sieht ja es in der logik
der sache das wird wohl so sagen ja herr
bissigen spätestens in einem monat
können es wieder alte kann es wieder
ältere menschen treffen die können
wieder schwer und schwerkranken soll die
politik warten bis die zahl der
erkrankten hochgeht oder sagen sie es
ist durchaus sinnvoll in der strategie
zu haben also eine strategie zu haben
ist sehr sinnvoll deswegen haben wir die
auch in deutschland wir haben die früh
entwickelt wir haben auch in einem finde
ich beispiellosen konnten konsens mit
bundesregierung die länder die kommunen
etwas auf den weg gebracht was großartig
war gegenseitiges vertrauen die
opposition in den parlamenten hat gesagt
ja wir vertrauen macht dass es wurden
rechte der regierung übertragen vom
bundestag das war eine wunderbare sache
und wir haben jetzt auch erfahrungen
gesammelt und wir müssen natürlich
vorbereitet sein gleichzeitig müssen wir
aber auch
stärker mit dem virus und seiner präsenz
leben wir müssen das deswegen auch mehr
diskutieren wir müssen auch zum beispiel
das großartige was wir haben unser
parlament stärker nutzen diskutieren
wird auch dieser dinge machen wir
abwägungs vorgänger sie haben eben zu
recht gesagt wir müssen abwägen auch der
bildungsanspruch von kindern von jungen
menschen der muss ja auch mit in die
abwägung hinein
wir müssen auch wirtschaftliche fragen
mit abwägen ländlich finanzieren wir
unser gesundheitswesen auf der grundlage
unseres wirtschaftlichen erfolges und
all diesen fragen stellen sich in der
bevölkerung viele wenden sich inzwischen
abkommen nicht mehr mit weil sie sagen
uns wird zu wenig erklärt wir können
diese abrechnungsprozesse der politik
nicht ausreichend nachvollziehen und das
liegt daran dass zu wenig
parlamentarisch debattiert wird über
diese dinge und das beklagen sie jetzt
schon zum dritten mal
dennoch die frage es bleibt ja am ende
eine politische entscheidung und die
zentrale frage wieviel infektionen man
also zulässt und mit wie wenn sie sagen
wir müssen damit leben heißt das
automatisch wieviel infizierte wir auch
zu lassen gegebenenfalls eben auch tote
zu lassen weil wir mit einem bestimmten
risiko leben also wie viele
infektionszahlen wir zulassen können
müssen wir da müssen wir auf die
fachleute vertrauen das können wir sehr
schwer politisch festlegen müssen auf
die fachleute ist am ende eine
politische entscheidung jeder arzt wird
erst mal sagen im infizierten ist helfen
und wir müssen jeden infekt jede
infektion vermeiden treu es am ende eine
politische entscheidung welche maßnahmen
nicht anordnen
diese maßnahmen sind
grundrechtseingriffe und das sind das
sind schwere eingriffe die tangieren die
freiheitsrechte von bürgerinnen und
bürgern
er kann niemals gelten so viel wie
möglich sondern nur so wenig wie nötig
aber so wenig wie möglich dass uns sehr
dass die der geist des grundgesetzes
ich kann nicht hergehen und kann sagen
aus präventionsgründen mache ich jetzt
mal maximale grundrechtseingriffe dann
wird schon nichts passieren sondern ich
muss das wirklich begründen kann im
einzelfall und wir haben beispiele
gehabt wir haben zum beispiel in
rheinland-pfalz gesagt wir wollen nicht
dass die polizei private haushalte
kontrolliert wer sich dort aufhält
deswegen machen wir keine vorgaben wie
man sich privat trifft und das hat sehr
gut funktioniert das zeigt also man kann
den menschen vertragen eben und wir
können ohnehin ohne die
eigenverantwortung der bürgerinnen und
bürger ganz schwer was erreichen wir
können nicht bei jeder
sie waren in berlin polizei wird fahren
was uns so viel beamte haben wir gar
nicht die verbinden in rheinland pfalz
jetzt auch diese corona ampel ein weil
wir uns vorbereiten so gehört sich das
auch und es ist ja ein sehr
differenzierter blick da werden eben
nicht nur die neuinfektionen angeschaut
sondern auch die zahl der schwerst
erkrankten und die zahl der toten ist
das nicht eben auch schon ein angebot an
den bürger für eine differenzierte
betrachtung dessen was wir tun doch wir
müssen das auch machen wir müssen
differenziert vorgehen und nochmal wir
müssen weil grundrechtseingriffen so
wenig wie irgendwie möglich das ist die
vorgabe und gleichzeitig müssen wir
unsere abwägungs vorgänger den bürger
transparent machen die menschen
mitnehmen
wie kann man etwas zutrauen und das ist
ein großartiger in unserer demokratie
ist die menschen dass wir das auch tun
genau deshalb sitzen wir hier auch in
dieser sendung frau trotz der frage an
sie warum hat man sich eigentlich nicht
längst auf so ein bundesweites corona
ampelsystem verständigt eben genau um
jeden bürger zu informieren und ihnen
auch leicht und schnell zu informieren
also ich glaube dass so ein ampelsystem
wie berlin das hat schon sehr sinnvoll
ist und ich glaube dass es auch gut ist
andere parameter mit einzubeziehen als
jetzt nur die reinen infektionszahlen zu
messen und dadurch macht man
entscheidungen auch wirklich
nachvollziehbarer und wie wir gerade
schon gehört haben sie es halt extrem
wichtig die menschen mitzunehmen ist
nützt alles nichts wenn wir irgendwelche
empfehlungen machen oder die politik
vorgaben macht und die menschen nicht
mitmachen der weg den wir bisher hatten
sind die menschen die gerade sagen das
verhalten der menschen bezahlt natürlich
ein auch auf diese gute bilanz wird das
virus am ende vielleicht dadurch auch
weniger gefährlich eben weil die
menschen sich durchaus grosso modo sehr
verantwortlich verhalten und mich jeden
tag protestieren
ja das virus selber wird sich jetzt
natürlich nicht so direkt an den
menschen orientieren
das hat ja seine eigene eigene dynamik
aber das infektionsgeschehen lässt sich
natürlich extrem durch das verhalten
beeinflussen und im moment sehen wir
ganz ganz viele infektionen bei den
jungen menschen und dass man kann auch
nachvollziehen dass die jetzt durch
diese frühjahrszeit es gab viele
einschränkungen wirklich mal so das
gefühl hatten wir müssen auch wieder
feiern
aber ich darf auch die junge menschen
können wir mitnehmen auch die wissen es
gibt junge menschen die eine multiple
sklerose haben das steht nicht auf der
brust das steht auch nicht auf der
stirne die müssen medikamente nehmen die
sind gefährdet die jungen menschen
wissen auch sie haben eltern sie haben
großeltern
wenn sie also zu viel party machen dann
gefährden sie andere und ich glaube wenn
wir das immer wieder auch den leuten
bewusst machen und gerade den jungen
menschen auch bewusst machen dann machen
die auch mit und dann bin ich da
eigentlich guter dinge dass wir wie sie
vorhin gesagt haben die katastrophe in
deutschland auch verhindern können die
zentrale ursache für die steigenden
fallzahlen herr müller wird ja jetzt
gerade in der freimuth gesehen das ist
nun schon ein paar mal gesagt worden und
auch in dem verhalten der jungen leute
das ist eben offensichtlich darin auch
begründet jetzt sagt der gesundheits
chef von reinickendorf herscheid wenn
der senat ist wirklich ernst meinen
würde müsste er diese partys und die
feiern mal grundsätzlich verbieten ja so
weit es geht machen und das ist
natürlich auch es gibt natürlich auch
illegale partys und dann muss man mit
polizeieinsatz dann natürlich auch gegen
vorgehen wir machen das auch schon aber
das muss mit sicherheit auch verschärft
werden wir haben gerade bei den 20 bis
40 jährigen das ist die gruppe wo wir
sehen wie die zahlen nach oben schießen
das ist da haben wir nun mal die
situation dass die sehr mobilen sind
dass die in der stadt viel unterwegs
sind dass die reisen dass die eben auch
feiern auch vor den gaststätten feiern
und darauf muss man reagieren und ich
glaube auch mehr als wir das bisher
getan haben wenn sie treten nicht noch
mal als regierender bürgermeister an sie
könnten jetzt eine unpopuläre
entscheidung fällen könnten sagen gibt
es nicht mehr
es gibt ja eigentlich die sagen das sind
schon unpopuläre entscheidung ich glaube
es sind angemessene und besondere
entscheidung aber noch einmal es geht
nicht mehr und teile ich die meinung es
geht nicht darum einfach mal zu sehen
was geht wohl alles aus zu testen was
die bevölkerung mitträgt wir reden hier
wirklich über grundrechte
nun ist es ein abwägungsprozess der
gesundheitsschutz ist eben auch ein
recht dass viele zu recht einfordern und
sagen ich will mich nicht gefahren
aussetzen durch sorglosigkeit anderer
und die politik hat nun mal die aufgabe
auch dieses zusammenleben zu gestalten
und zu regeln und wenn ich sehe wenn ich
zb in berlin gesehen
dass die ersten wochen mit masken
pflicht im öpnv nicht gut liefen
da muss man nach steuern muss es zur
pflicht machen muss das bußgeld bewerten
und dann hat es auch funktioniert und wo
doch akzeptiert von vielen
und an dieser stelle sind wir genau zu
überlegen mit welcher maßnahme kann ich
zielgerichtet auch die situation
beherrschen ok krankheit entstehen wenn
jetzt sogar münchen ein alkoholverbot
ausruft wäre dann nicht irgendwie auch
endlich mal an der zeit in berlin des
biturbo zu verbieten oder jetzt sowieso
keinen sinn weil man sich nicht dran
hält also ich selber trinkt überhaupt
kein alkohol also ich hätte nichts
dagegen kann er sich aber
also ich glaub nicht so richtig daran
ich glaube es geht alles in den
untergrund und es wird dazu führen dass
die leute dann nicht mehr zur testung
kommen also wenn sie wissen sie machen
was illegal ist und sich dann die sind
bestens vernetzt also ich hab nämlich
genau diese leute die kommen und die
wissen schon dass sie wahrscheinlich
infiziert sind und isolieren sie gehen
auf die party aber dann gehen sie nach
hause und isolieren sich also das ist so
ein zwiegespaltene geschichte sie sind
trotzdem verantwortlich und ich finde
vielmehr die lösung wäre den antigenen
schnelltest jedem zugänglich zu machen
dann geht er auf die feier und wenn dann
irgendwie ein hotspot entstanden ist
dann lässt er sich auch schnell testen
und das kann ein patient auch selber
machen
man muss ja nicht irgendeine autorität
gehen also wichtig ist dass die
patienten das autonomie bekommen ja und
der hand haben vielleicht werden wir
gleich noch erklären noch gibt es den
nicht meldung von deutschland ich kann
ihn bestellen
sie können ihn bestellen heute meldet
orange dass der auf den markt kommen
soll und in 15 minuten schon sagen würde
ob man corona hat oder nicht krone hat
das würde tatsächlich vieles verbessern
sagen wir gleich herr wissing partys
feiern geburtstage hochzeiten hochzeiten
sollen die menschen in ihren augen in
den augen der fdp das jetzt einfach
weitermachen oder sagen sie dann muss es
beschränkungen geben es gibt ja
beschränkungen es gibt die klare regeln
die müssen beachtet werden es gibt auch
beschränkungen was die zahlen angeht er
aber auch hier gilt man kann nicht
einfach hergehen und kann den leuten
sagen ihr dürft überhaupt keine
hochzeitsfeier mitmachen man muss sich
auch mal überlegen was das heißt zu was
können sie nicht nachholen es ist auch
sehr schwer wenn sie niedrige zahlen sei
von gästen die erlaubt sind sagen sie
ist 30 gäste
das ist dann sehr schöne veranstaltung
wenn man sagen wollen sie und verwandten
sagen darfst du bist der 31 ja das ist
wirklich schwierig und das soll ja auch
ein schöner tag im leben sein und wir
müssen wir abwägen und wir müssen uns
als politiker ganz stark manchmal
stärker als es der fall ist bewusst sein
was für massive grundrechtseingriffe das
sind oder nehmen sie trauerfeier
die können sie auch nicht nachholen und
die sind tatsächlich aber ehrlich nicht
das problem trauerfeiern und hochzeiten
sind es nicht sondern es ist das lockere
feiern miteinander auf partys jetzt sind
diese lockerungen offensichtlich an
steigende infektionszahlen schuld und
sie wollen mehr lockern fragezeichen wir
haben in rheinland-pfalz gerade
gelockert weil sich bei uns das
infektionsgeschehen stabilisiert hatten
wir keine neue dynamik haben parallel
dazu höre ich in anderen bundesländern
dass man zügel anziehen will
ich mag die sprache schon nicht im
vergleich von von regierung zum bürger
aber das ist eine andere sache ich habe
da eine andere vorstellung davon ich
will nicht nur eine möglichkeit staat
leben der mich behandelt wie wie bei der
kavallerie sondern ich möchte dass man
mir erklärt dass abgewogen wird aber
wieder als stadien und große weinfeste
sagen sie sind zu riskant also schöne
dinge gehen nicht der der wurstmarkt in
bad dürkheim wird nicht stattfinden
können das ist klar und natürlich werden
auch wir dort das oktoberfest oder kann
nicht stattfinden konnte die stattfinden
das sind alles dinge die sind eher
logisch und nachvollziehbar aber wir
müssen uns die frage stellen schaffen
wir das nicht zum beispiel
weihnachtsmärkte in einer art und weise
zu organisieren dass die sehnsucht der
menschen nach solchen dingen auch
zufriedengestellt werden kann und wir
vielleicht auch dort dokumentations-
möglichkeiten wir haben es gibt ja auch
die er wird ja nachgedacht genau also
das ist leider mussten wir auch ja und
genau das ist auch ganz ganz notwendig
dass wir das tun und ich mag noch mal
gesagt noch mal ich mag diese zügel
anzugs rhetorik melden mögen diese
sprache nicht haben wir hier auch noch
nicht im mund genommen hat
natürlich gerne söder sagte dass um dass
da irgendwas gleich zuzuordnen und ich
will sagen es sind auch und das gehört
auch dazu politik muss auch
selbstkritisch sein es sind auch dinge
angeordnet worden die über den man über
das ziel hinaus geschossen hat und diese
geschichten wie öffnungs diskussions
orgien wo menschen sagen wir müssen doch
ein abwägungs vorgang haben wir müssen
doch
wir müssen doch wissen ist das wirklich
angemessen war in einer absoluten
unsicherheit und das ist tatsächlich ja
dann auch kassiert worden und es wurde
gelacht aber es waren doch genau diese
debatten die dazu geführt haben dass die
maßnahmen immer präziser wurden an damit
auch immer verfassungskonform geben
obwohl es die kritik wie sowieso wo
kommt die berechtigung her an solchen
abwägungsprozess in solchen diskussionen
kritik haben wir hier gemacht insofern
findet das statt frau teichert man
zwingt die menschen ins private und
wundert sich darüber
das ist natürlich nicht zu kontrollieren
ist wie der privat gefeiert ist also ich
würde gerne noch mal dass ein bisschen
klarstellen wir haben jetzt die ganze
zeit über private feiern und solche
geschichten gesprochen aber das risiko
da aber wir reden über ein virus wir
reden über erkrankungen wir reden über
risikogruppen wir reden über menschen
die erkranken können und auch das muss
man in den blick nehmen und nicht nur
jetzt diese ganze lockerungs geschichte
diskutieren sondern sich auch eigentlich
noch mal vor augen führen was ist da was
liegt da auf der anderen seite auf der
waagschale
auch wenn wir über tests und
schnelltests reden dann möchte ich
zunächst nicht dass die für die feiern
sage ich mal aufgewendet werden das kann
man machen wenn man genug hat aber wenn
wir nicht genug haben da müssen wir doch
erst mal an die risikogruppen denken und
wir müssen an die menschen denken die
wir schützen müssen
und da haben wir jetzt so sagen haben in
der diskussion jetzt eben eher in die
andere richtung geguckt ich würde es
gerne noch mal so ein bisschen umlenken
das ist durchaus leben eben auch
besorgniserregende erkrankungen geht ja
und das ist wichtig dass sie darauf
nochmal hinweisen die politik kann jetzt
natürlich eine bestimmte größe einer
feier einschränken aber kann sie dann am
ende auch kontrollieren ob die ausartet
wie der bürgermeister von haben zuletzt
formuliert hat also das ist genau das
was wir jetzt miteinander hier
besprechen wie schwierig das ist mit
welchen maßnahmen man sozusagen was
kontrollieren kann und wo die politik
daran handlungsfeld hat das ist ein
ringen miteinander was hier passiert
aber man muss sich diesen fragen stellen
aber trotzdem nochmal man sollte nicht
nur sich sozusagen mit dem vergnügen
beschäftigen auch wenn ich das gut
nachvollziehen kann das sind wichtige
diskussion aber wir haben das thema
risikopatient wir haben bildung und
alles mögliche
seinem kontext auch eine rolle spielt
und auch da muss man hinguckt so und
natürlich haben wir auch viele
hoffnungen gehabt wir haben hoffnung
gehabt auf schnelltests wir hatten
hoffnungen auf die app und natürlich
auch auf den impfstoff das wurde nicht
alles versprochen
die suche nach dem richtigen mittel sie
läuft auf hochtouren
stress für die wissenschaft weltweit
wird gegen das virus gekämpft einen
fertigen impfstoff gibt es trotzdem noch
nicht dass wir im herbst einen impfstoff
haben halte ich für unmöglich
für die meisten heißt das weiter warten
immerhin ein schnelltest soll ab sofort
zur verfügung stehen anzuwenden durch
medizinisches personal die korona app
dagegen schlägt nicht immer im richtigen
moment alle haben zb ein fall hat die
app eine warnung herausgegeben
und es stellte sich dann heraus es waren
mieter in zwei wohnungen nebeneinander
aber dazwischen war eine wand sechs
monate nach pandemie beginnt bleibt
vieles beim alten
drei buchstaben das maß der dinge
abstand hygiene
das mosten haben wir vielleicht mal mit
der app an und kommen dann noch zu den
tests vor katzenstein wie viele menschen
sind von der app informiert worden und
in ihre praxis gekommen
nicht mal eine handvoll also sozusagen
niemand ich selber krieg 14 risiko
begegnungen am tag immer gemeldet
darauf reagiere ich dann auch nicht weil
das natürlich praxis bedingt ist also
ist jetzt hilft den meisten leute kommen
weil symptomatisch sind oder weil sie in
kontakt hatten
sie sagen freitag jetzt interessanter
weise entlastet das bisher auch
überhaupt nicht die arbeit der
gesundheitsämter
es sollte ja mal eine wunderwaffe seien
diese waren app auf den smartphones und
jetzt schreibt der stern
es sei ein rohrkrepierer geworden also
das würde ich so nicht stehen lassen
wir haben ähnliche beobachtungen auch
die anzahl der leute die sich über die
app melden ist nicht so stark aber der
die app ist nicht dafür konzipiert um
die gesundheitsämter zu entlasten dass
mir noch mal ganz wichtig das zu sagen
sondern die app ist ein technisches
hilfsmittel ja was auch ohne
berechtigung hat klar braucht man
digitale strukturen in diesen systemen
auch und es kann helfen bei der pandemie
aber sie sollen nicht die gesundheitsamt
dann lassen es war noch nie vorgesehen
deswegen tut es auch nicht aber das war
ja auch nicht verabredet dass wir das
machen soll sondern der andere punkt
sollte auch sensibilisieren immer sollte
darauf aufmerksam machen wo gefahren
sein könnten und dann wenn diese risiko
meldungen kommen wieder darauf
aufmerksam machen du kannst jetzt etwas
tun es nimmt einen nicht die
eigenverantwortung ab es ist ein
baustein in einer riesen strategie es
sollte vor allen dingen viel viel
schneller gehen und es sollte vermeiden
dass man sich per fax noch informiert
herr wissing wenn es jetzt weniger die
technik ist sondern in diesem fall mehr
der datenschutz ist der die effizienz
dieser waren erstmal noch nicht liefert
wofür würde sich dann diesmal die fdp
entscheiden würden sie sagen es wäre
klug gewesen nicht so sehr auf den
datenschutz zu pochen
und man könnte es ja so machen dass man
die dass der nutzer der app die
entscheidung treffen kann auf den
datenschutz zu verzichten die
möglichkeit gibt es ja es ist freiwillig
das land freiwillig zwei an und ich bin
sicher viele werden das tun diejenigen
die die app runterladen die wollen
natürlich auch einen maximalen schutz
durch die app erreichen und
man die informationen weitergeben würde
hätte das hätte das sicherlich einen
zusätzlichen nutzen 1 haben wir gelernt
glaube ich und das kann ich jetzt nicht
vorwurfsvoll in irgendeine richtung aber
als ersten auftrag für die ganze
gesellschaft die app kam spät
wir haben sind solchen systemen zu wenig
erfahrungen und das sollte uns allen
eine mahnung sein wir sind bei dem stand
der digitalisierung und das ist das
bitter vor augen geführt worden nicht
weit genug in deutschland
und deswegen muss da jetzt gas geben
werden das haben wir im bildungsbereich
im übrigen auch erlebt so und jetzt eine
digitalisierung die kette ist ja sofort
wieder gezogen lang dauerte es mit der
app meines wissens eben weil diese
datenschutzbestimmungen entsprechend
eingebaut werden mussten da bleibt auf
jeden fall noch eine menge zu tun
momentan ist diese waren app tatsächlich
nur von vier prozent der menschen auch
mit den entsprechenden informationen
gespeist und das schreit jetzt nicht
wirklich nach einem granaten erfolg
nächste wichtige punkt ist das testen
frau katzenstein hat schon angesprochen
das testen
tun wir jetzt mehr sollte den alltag
sicherer machen würden sie sagen wie
frau katzenstein fordert im grunde
müssten wir den bürgern auch das meer in
die hand geben dass sie sich dann testen
lassen können wenn sie es wollen
ja natürlich ist das ganz klar dass wir
auch diese systeme ausbauen müssen wir
nutzen im moment aber die kapazitäten
natürlich bevorzugt für die
risikogruppen oder für die ganz
sensiblen bereichen in den pflegeheimen
in den schulen doch in den schulen wird
getestet sowohl bei den schülern wie
auch bei den lehrern es wird in den
kitas getestet es wird in den
verwaltungen wird getestet das wird bei
der polizei und bei der feuerwehr
getestet natürlich nutzen wir dafür
kapazitäten und es werden auch die sehr
schnell getestet die entweder symptome
haben oder aus risikogebieten kommen
oder risiko kontakte haben sie sprechen
ja die an die eben gefeiert haben und
sagen jetzt hätte ich aber schon gerne
eine sicherheit ob bei mir alles in
ordnung ist oder nicht und da
tatsächlich da ist es wünschenswert dass
wir viel mehr test kapazitäten bekommen
viel schnellere ergebnisse und das dann
tatsächlich auf alle ausweiten können
aber im moment müssen wir noch
prioritäten setzen
also ich darf zum beispiel selbst als
corvette 19 schwerpunktpraxis lehrer
nicht testen
ich würde mich zum beispiel auch sehr
gerne und das habe ich auch getan als
schul ärztin der schule meiner kinder
anbieten und der schule meines mannes
der ist nämlich lehrer
das darf ich nicht das wurde mir gesagt
das wird von der schulaufsicht nicht
genehmigt ja sie wissen dass die charité
das für berlin übernommen hat und
federführend diese testung an den
schulen vornimmt weil wir die daten
zusammenführen wollen und auch wieder
sehr zielgerichtet und schnell reagieren
wollen durch die erkenntnisse der
charité aber wie realistisch ist das
dass ein lehrer ohne symptome
zwei stunden durch die stadt fährt sich
an der charité anstellt also das muss
doch auch dezentralisiert und lebensnah
sein wer das an den schulen und kitas
vorgenommen
nein da doch das testung an schulen und
kitas und bestimmt darüber hinaus gibt
es noch angebote dann an den stellen an
den institutionen der charité wo man
sich auch testen lassen kann
also es gibt 30.000 lehrer in berlin die
kapazitäten würden niemals ausreichend
für diese 30.000 lehrer sich testen zu
lassen
und es ist nicht realistisch dass 30.000
lehrer zur charité um sich testen zu
lassen machen die natürlich nicht auf
einen schlag müssen sie auch nicht
das soll ja mit zwei wochen rhythmus
sein und so es könnte vielleicht auch
für diese note für diese test note eine
lösung geben frau potter ich habe es
vorhin schon erwähnt
es gibt die meldung dass es einen
schnelltest geben könnte der in 15
minuten ein ergebnis ausweist und nicht
wie dieser pcr-test frühestens 48
stunden wirklich frühestens glauben sie
daran dass das wirklich bald für jeden
zu haben ist sage ich mal
also ich glaube es gibt zwei punkte die
man hier noch mal berücksichtigen muss
zum einen müssen wir uns natürlich
überlegen wie er braucht wirklich die
tester und dann bin ich immer noch bei
ihnen dass die tester brauchen
diejenigen die symptomatisch sind und
diejenigen die wirklich ein risiko
hatten wir sind in der luxus situation
in deutschland dass wir auch rein teste
belehrung lehrern machen können oder ein
test der bei schülern zumindest in
studien machen könne
aber frau teichert hat es ja auch gesagt
ich glaube wir müssen uns wirklich noch
mal ein bisschen darauf konzentrieren wo
sind denn die wichtigen bereiche wo sind
die risikopatienten die wir schützen
müssen
und wie müssen wir gezielt können wir
gezielt auch unsere ressourcen einsetzen
wir werden mehr tests tatsächlich helfen
würden frau potter dann müsste bayern
doch ein bisschen besser dastehen oder
ich glaube dieses virus kann man nicht
einfach weg testen
also dieses virus kann man abhalten
indem man abstand hält indem man masken
trägt und in dem man vernünftige
hygienemaßnahmen einhält und man muss es
vor allem von demjenigen abhalten die
ein risiko haben das sind die älteren
mitbürger das sind aber auch durchaus
jüngere die vorerkrankungen haben und
auf die um die müssen wir uns da kümmern
ich glaube wir sind so ein bisschen zu
sehr gefangen darin zu versuchen das
ganze irgendwo weg zu testen oder so
komplett in den griff zu kriegen mit
testen dass das wird nicht funktionieren
also dem schnelltest der genau danach
wollte ich sie gerade noch mal fragen
wie was halten sie davon glauben sie
dass das kommt und denken sie dass das
helfen würde weil man den menschen eben
einfach in die aktiver setzt und die
dinge nicht mehr so lange brauchen 15
minuten sind nicht zwei oder vier tage
also eine moderne pcr test der ist auch
in zwei stunden fertig das problem ist
nicht mal so sehr die geschwindigkeit
die ich im labor habe sondern das
problem ist wie wir auch schon gehört
haben ich muss einen termin bekommen wo
ich irgendwann einen abstrich machen
lassen kann dann muss dieses material
ins labor transportiert werden und dann
muss es im labor aufgearbeitet werden
und daher kommen diese 24 bis 48 stunden
dass es nicht die testdauer an sich was
es wirklich schneller machen würde ist
wenn jemand zu hause einen test machen
könnte und sein ergebnis haben könnte
und dann sagen okay ich habe einen
kontakt gehabt ich habe möglicherweise
ein positives ergebnis aber im moment
diese schnelltests tätige bisher haben
die sind dafür gemacht im labor
durchgeführt zu werden und das hat auch
einen grund denn ich handhabe ja
material was potentiell infektiös ist
und das kann ich nicht einfach vor dem
altersheim handhaben da kann ich mich
jemand hin stellen der dann infektiöses
material handhabt sich vielleicht selber
ansteckt und das ganze mit rein trägt
dass das funktioniert nicht
deswegen sagen auch die firmen bisher
das muss eben eine medizinische
fachkraft machen und nach in der praxis
muss ich dann entsprechende sicherheits
werkbänke haben die mich oder demjenigen
der den testern durchführt auch schützt
wenn wenn dein infektiöses material ist
doch sie wollen altersheim ist nicht
ganz so einfach auch von altersheimen
könnte man ja jemanden stellen der davon
ahnung hat das ist auch ein abstrich
test funktioniert ähnlich wie ein
schwangerschaftstest also wird auch im
rachen ein abstrich gemacht
das kann ja durchaus jemand tun dann
wäre ein altersheim und eine schule
sofort zeigt aber sie brauchen ja auch
noch die infrastruktur dadurch also
derjenige muss wissen wie er den test
macht aber der braucht auch eine
sicherheits werkbank der kann das nicht
einfach an der frischen luft machen
sonst setzt er sich ja selber auch einem
risiko aus und das ist eben nicht so
einfach umzusetzen sie können jemandem
der potenzielle infiziert ist seinen
eigenen test in die hand geben denn er
kann sich ja nicht von sich selber
anstecken aber jemanden der einen test
für jemand anders auf arbeitet der muss
natürlich irgendwo eine
schutzvorrichtung haben und das sehen
auch unsere ganzen arbeit
schutzvorrichtungen vorgaben in
deutschland ein herr wir sind das heißt
am ende wieder vor allen dingen vorsicht
und fertigt oder wir müssen diese
möglichkeiten gibt es auch mit dem
schnelltest nutzen weil wir können nicht
auf dauer auf alles verzichten
wir sehen im moment stehen wir vor einer
schweren wirtschaftskrise oder mitten in
einer schweren wirtschaftskrise deren
auswirkungen in der in der breite erst
noch auf uns zukommen könnten haben wir
letzte woche darüber diskutiert ja und
das ist zu recht ja weil das ein ernstes
thema ist und wir müssen und schon wir
sind eine exportnation wir müssen uns
mit der frage beschäftigen wir können
wie können wir unsere geschäftskontakte
im ausland aufrecht erhalten wir können
nicht einfach sagen zur sicherheit
stellen wir die einfach bis auf
unbestimmte zeit ein
ich erinner nochmal hand unser
gesundheitssystem das sehr valide ist
das basiert auch auf unseren
wirtschaftlichen erfolg und deswegen
müssen wir solche schnelltests auch
nutzen um zu recht die bevölkerung zu
schützen wenn geschäftsleute ins ausland
reisen sich schnell testen zu können um
schnell zu wissen in ich ein risiko wenn
ich wieder zurückkommen was aber nicht
funktioniert ist auf dauer zu sagen wir
stellen einfach diese ganzen reisen
dann wird schon nichts passieren weil
die konsequenzen mittelbar auch für das
gesundheitswesen ziemlich seine
finanzierung werden wir dann bitte ok
drinnen sie dann trotzdem sagen dass die
menschen jetzt besser auf den
herbsturlaub verzichten
also ich denke dass ich sehr ist es sehr
ratsam auf urlaubsreisen die ja
verzichtbar sind in risikogebiete
wirklich zu verzichten das ist glaube
ich sehr ratsam
aber es ist nicht auf dauer möglich und
auch nicht auf längere sicht hin möglich
dass wir den geschäftsreiseverkehr auf
eis legen und hier sie schon ein
ernsthaftes problem
wir haben wir hängen auch an unserer
anderen luftfahrtgesellschaften die im
augenblick hunderte von millionen
verluste machen jeden monat
die frage ist was bleibt am ende davon
noch übrig und deswegen plädiere ich
sehr dafür dass wir diese schnelltest
nutzen wo immer es möglich um sie so
schnell wie möglich auch einzusetzen
wir haben die den großen wunsch
natürlich diese pandemie nicht nur
besser zu verstehen sondern im
allerschönsten fall sogar ein bisschen
präzise in die zukunft zu schauen dabei
können epidemiologen helfen mit ihren
rechenmodellen und deshalb freue ich
mich jetzt in braunschweig michael meyer
hermann zu begrüßen
einen schönen guten abend nach
braunschweig meyer hermann halle vor
das ist doch schon mal wunderbar die
schlimmsten vorhersagen herr meyer
hermann fangen wir vielleicht mitmachen
die schlimmsten vorhersagen sind bisher
nicht eingetroffen ist ist da nicht
logisch dass sich viele deutsche
wünschen dass dieses land einfach auch
weiter eine wunderbare ausnahme bleibt
ja das ist total nachvollziehbar und
dennoch würde ich an der stelle
versuchen die zahlen die wir haben kurz
zu bewerten
wir haben so etwas wie 2000 fälle pro
tag im moment neue fälle neuinfektionen
das ist ungefähr die zahl der fälle die
wir im april hatten als wir über
lockerungen gesprochen haben also
insofern könnte man jetzt argumentieren
da können wir jetzt ja auch wieder über
lockerungen sprechen aber es gibt einen
massiven unterschied zwischen den 2009
fällen die wir im april hatten und in
2009 fällen die wir jetzt haben
in den 2000 fällen im april war es so
dass wie in einer abfallenden fallzahl
waren
jetzt ist es so dass wir seit mitte juni
wo wir 300 fälle pro tag hatten auf
2.000 fälle wieder angestiegen sind also
dass man jetzt von einer stabilität
sprechen kann kann also sich maximal im
wochenbereich abspielen es ist glaube
ich nicht wirklich möglich dass man
jetzt sagt es ist in deutschland eine
stabile situation sie ist stabiler als
im ausland
also wenn wir nach frankreich und auch
spanien gucken dann ist sie deutlich
stabiler aber wir sind im grunde mit
einem faktor 8 mehr fällen jetzt seit
juni und das ist schon massive anstieg
das bedeutet wir müssen schon aufpassen
in welche richtung wir laufen und was
für maßnahmen wie jetzt zu lassen können
und danach gleich noch mal zu fragen
in frankreich spanien griechenland war
haben wir irgendetwas besser gemacht als
die anderen
ja ich denke dass also das sehen wir in
den simulationen auch ganz deutlich wenn
man früher reagiert dann kann man die
fallzahlen vom niveau her unten halten
das ist die reaktion die die man sofort
nachvollziehen kann also eine woche
früher ist ein unglaublicher unterschied
das ist ein exponentielles wachstum
deswegen ist eine woche total wichtig
aber deswegen darf man auch nicht
vergessen dass das was jetzt die
nächsten zwei wochen passiert ist das
was wir die zwei wochen vorher gemacht
haben
diese zeitverzögerung die ist ja nicht
anders geworden die haben wir damals
schon diskutiert als überbringer über
lockerungen gesprochen haben die gilt
jetzt genauso
ja wir können gar nicht mehr
beeinflussen was in der nächsten woche
für fallzahlen sein werden das sind die
zahlen die wir einfach letzten in den
letzten zwei wochen schon generiert
haben deswegen müssen wir wirklich
aufpassen und die signale ganz genau
lesen denn in dem moment wo wir über
eine bestimmte schwelle rüberkommen ist
es ganz schwer gegenzusteuern und
manchmal kriegt man das schiff nicht
mehr um
haben sie in diesen letzten sechs
monaten eine wesentlich verlässlichere
daten basis bekommen in bezug auf
dunkelziffer auf tätlichkeit auf die
inkubationszeit auf die haupt
übertragungswege ja natürlich diese
ganzen parameter fuhren sich fest also
gerade die inkubationszeit die sie
genannt haben ist ein gutes beispiel
am anfang haben wir mit 5,2 tagen
gerechnet dass waren eine war von einer
analyse aus china mit 24 patienten also
das war statistisch einfach nicht sehr
sauber inzwischen sind die
inkubationszeit ein bis acht tage hoch
gegangen die man sieht und auch
wesentlich besserer statistischer basis
also da haben sich sehr viele dinge
getan und man weiß sehr viel mehr als
vorher die dunkelziffer ist ein
schwieriges thema die kann man immer nur
abschätzen da würde ich sagen ist noch
viel zu tun
aber natürlich werden dadurch die
vorhersagen auch verlässlicher die wir
machen können mit den epidemiologischen
modellen aber da möchte ich auch
trotzdem darauf hinweisen das ist
eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig am ende
weil die strukturellen aussagen die wir
machen verändern sich durch die
parameter die man ein bisschen nach oben
oder unten schiebt nicht da geht es
vielleicht darum ob wir die
quarantänezeit jetzt um ein oder zwei
tage verkürzen können das ist die frage
die man damit vielleicht genauer
beantworten kann ok simulationen dieser
laufenden prozesse das sagen sie gerade
die sind wahnsinnig schwierig und am
kompliziertesten ist wahrscheinlich das
verhalten der menschen zu simulieren ja
also wenn wir jetzt mit
differentialgleichungen modellen
arbeiten was so sie klassischen
epidemiologischen modelle sind da ist
das verhalten der menschen gibt das
kommt ja noch nicht vor
also das ist dann gar nicht enthalten
deswegen machen wir agenten basierte
modelle in den agenten basierten
modellen ist jede person abgebildet und
im computer und dann kann man natürlich
auch nicht das verhalten vorhersagen
weil wir sind ja keine psychologen wobei
wir jetzt sogar ein projekt anfangen mit
soziologen um tatsächlich da eine
bessere basis zu haben wie menschen in
einer konstellation reagieren aber man
kann immerhin gucken wie voll ist der
kühlschrank und das könnte man also im
computer abbilden das heißt wird der
mensch jetzt in den supermarkt gehen
oder licht und gibt es einen guten grund
für ihn in den supermarkt zu gehen also
auf der ebene könnte man tatsächlich
schon modelle machen
und das ist eine form von verhaltens
abbildung die dann mehr auf so einer
statistischen ebene mit
wahrscheinlichkeiten also dann kann man
es vielleicht nochmal anders fragen und
besser fragen
es ist ja von anfang an klar gewesen
dass nicht hundert prozent der menschen
sich zu 100% an regeln halten an die
regeln und an andere kluge maßnahmen
halten würde es denn für die bekämpfung
der pandemie schon ausreichen wenn das
70 oder 60 prozent
sie sprechen mir gerade so aus der seele
also ein wesentlicher aspekt den ich
also mit der frage mal nicht weil war
ein wesentlicher aspekt den ich versuche
eigentlich rüber zu bringen ist wir
brauchen kein perfektes system um diese
pandemie zu beherrschen
ein perfektes system ist nicht die
zielsetzung wir werden immer damit leben
müssen dass es demonstranten gibt dass
es leute gibt die ungehemmt feiern und
dabei eben neue herde erzeugen das ist
ein normaler bestandteil einer jeden
funktionierenden gesellschaft das heißt
wir müssen unsere maßnahmen so
organisieren dass wir das tolerieren
können in der gesellschaft ein perfektes
system wird es niemals geben und
deswegen sind auch die
wahrscheinlichkeiten in den modellen
immer so gebaut dass es fehler gibt also
ist ein fehler trächtiges system und die
fehler gehören dazu und die möchte ich
eigentlich auch gar nicht eliminieren
weil das ist eigentlich eine lebendige
gesellschaft die damit abgebildet werden
sie haben herr meyer hermann damals im
april sehr dafür plädiert die diesen
deutschen lockdown gar nicht so schlimm
wie in anderen ländern diesen deutschen
lockdown zu verlängern um das virus
auszutrocknen
wie sehen sie das heute was wir damals
gemacht haben ist diese empfehlung hatte
zum ziel die 300 fälle pro tag die wir
dann im juni hatten schneller zu
erreichen
also wir haben zwei monate gebraucht das
hätte man wahrscheinlich auch in zwei
drei wochen schaffen können wenn wir den
doktor länger gehabt hätten aber in der
zeit hat uns das wetter geholfen wir
haben zeit draußen verbracht das hat das
ganze infektionsgeschehen verändert
jetzt ist es so dass wir mit den
gleichen zahlen da stehen aber wir haben
den winter vor uns das heißt wir haben
eine komplett andere situation wenn wir
jetzt
sagen wir lockern weiter dann haben wir
zusätzlich noch die kraft die saisonalen
kräfte die das ganze noch weiter
beschleunigen werden das heißt es ist
wirklich der falsche moment jetzt um
darüber nachzudenken ob man wirklich
fußball stadion öffnen sollte und die
partys wieder in ungehemmt zu lassen
sollte das ist einfach nicht das was wir
jetzt diskutieren sollten sondern wir
müssen zusehen dass wir die zahlen so
weit unten halten dass wir eine chance
haben durch den winter zu kommen ohne
dass es wirklich zu einer explosion der
fälle kommt michael meyer hermann ganz
herzlichen dank nach braunschweig heute
abend und wir sind unbedingt genau bei
dem zuletzt angesprochen